Scientists, technologists, innovators, they're just like you.
They love trying things.
Uncertain things.
Ambitious things.
Things that sound as crazy in our heads as they do out loud.
Those are the things that make us get up, brush our teeth,...
...and go risk our reputation on a hunch.
Trying something new is the only way to make the next great, whatever!
And the best part is we all know how to do it.
When you were a baby you unsuccessfully tried that new walking thing,...
...for like, four months, and now you walk like a champion.
Same with talking, swimming, riding a bike,...
..the desire to try new things is built into you.
Now take that desire, apply some science, and get ready to change the world.
What will you try?